well Andy you asked a very touchy
subject what came first the chicken or
the egg the galaxy or the black hole we
still don't know first of all if you
want to see the black hole at the center
of our own Milky Way galaxy go out
tonight and look in the direction of
Sagittarius that's where we have a super
massive black hole at the very center of
our own backyard the Milky Way galaxy it
weighs two to three million times the
mass of our Sun now the latest theory
about which came first is the following
first we think that out of the Big Bang
came dark matter invisible matter if I
held dark matter in my hand it would
literally lose its way right through my
fingers go right to the center of the
earth go to China and then go back and
forth between China and my hand
that's dark matter we think that dark
matter began to clump first because of
gravity then matter was attracted to the
clumpiness creating the supermassive
black hole and then later the galaxy
itself began to form we have computer
simulations about this but still the
relationship is not yet clear
now remember stars we know almost
everything about stellar evolution
that's because the Pentagon has given us
physicists billions of dollars to model
hydrogen bombs and a star is nothing but
a hydrogen bomb however a galaxy
consists of over a hundred billion stars
so it's much more difficult to tell
which came first the black hole or the
Galaxy itself